interviewer what is an abstract syntax  tree you  when we write code we want to use text  that is as concise as possible but  things like compilers want a lot more  information to fully understand your  code so first we perform lexical  analysis to tokenize all the different  parts of the code like variables  operators functions and so on it's like  finding all the nouns and verbs in a  sentence we then take that list of  tokens and parse it into a tree that  represents the structure of the code  this abstract syntax tree can then be  safely used by compilers to generate a  different type of code like turn  typescript code into javascript or c  plus plus into machine code